what's happening what we William to this
truck unloaded parties before [ __ ] I'm
begging you not okay don't talk to my
husband like that you come over here you
say that to my face come over here right
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you oh honey I
got on the road I've got him what's
going on with you he could just anxious
you know everybody walk with our friends
last week we was all before woman's here
turn 19 again it's a brooder the friend
group I know you love your college
friends but every time you get together
with them you'll become a bunch of
little [ __ ] you know loud we've got
like 20 years
ravenson Childre it all just get so
competitive don't have to plot every
time you hit the ball I don't even hear
myself I'm just still kind of really it
sounds like you're taking a [ __ ] I've
been here ten minutes you've taken 3,000
[ __ ] no that's how it sounds like when I
prove
I love my life I just wonder what would
happen if it was blown to smithereens
and I got stirred all over again so it
has nothing to do with your affair
stupid college hookup it never ended
calling it because you guys are married
to other people and having sex with each
other
[Music]
job they're evil genes [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so you went to hire how do you sleep
with women that are half your age in
soul-crushing
we're good people this party gonna be
called oh you're such bad people people
do you want to have a child I don't know
[Music]
the type of person have to have meaning
in their life
[Music]
it's just things that matter in this
world nipples and butts and he's got
offer
[Music]
I want everyone to know that after a
long talk with max last night I have
decided to go ahead and try to like you
[Applause]
what do you guys doing motion well no
it's really cool to swim oh yeah and
like wait slow
[Music]
you